hello my name is Bruno Oliveira and I
work in the play games team and we here
for second episode of play games and NDK
so now we're going to talk about how to
do achievements and leaderboards for
native game so to recap from from from
the last episode what we have right now
is you have your awesome game activity
which derives from native activity and
then we're implementing a few callbacks
and that in that class actually manages
the the game helper object so you're
just hooking hooking up the callbacks
and then game the game helper is
actually doing the the actual work so
how do you go ahead and unlock an
achievement from there so to unlock an
achievement first of all you have to the
code that you want to make is on on game
client you have a method that's called
unlock achievements so that's the method
that you want to go on get on games
client so normally this is how you would
do this however remember that your game
is going to be running on a game thread
that's different from the UI thread so
to prevent any synchronization problems
what we're going to do is we're going to
write a method called post unlock
achievement and that method is going to
call run on UI thread and then that
method is going to invoke the the unlock
achievement method on the UI thread so
that's what well the method that we're
going to call from from the native side
so next since we have that method all we
have to do is call it from native side
so to call it from the native side
you're going to need the achievement IDs
the achievement IDs can be can be can be
obtained from the developer console and
they are these funny-looking strings
that you see here so these funny alpha
numeric strings so going to have one
distinct string for each achievement
that your game has so once you have
those so this in this case this would be
a game where they prove theorems and
then you advance in your academic career
so once you have those IDs all you have
to do is call unlock achievements with
those IDs so first of all you have to
initialize all the jni stuff so we're
going to assume that you have that ready
so if you if you don't know how to do
that you can take a look at the last
video so you have your android app
structure you have your jni environment
we have the the activity object and the
activity class after you do that all i
have to do is just make a simple jane i
call to the unlock achievements method
so we are just getting the method ID
then we were allocating and java string
that corresponds to that achievement ID
and then we're making the year the
method call and remember and this is
pretty important we are also G
allocating the the java string after
we're done with that we're done with it
and that's pretty much all there is to
unlocking an achievement also you might
want to avoid repeated calls because Jay
and I calls are somewhat expensive so if
you're running a tight game loop and you
were calling unlock achievement all the
time you probably want to avoid that
that or that overhead so well one thing
that you can do is actually keep a
dictionary on the native side and that
tells you which achievement you have you
know you have unlocked and which ones
you don't know if you have unlocked or
not whenever you try to unlock an
achievement that you know you have
unlocked you can just return and not do
anything so we can do that using
something like the string SAT class
which is great for in every way except
the fact that it doesn't exist so you
actually have to implement your own and
string set structure in C++ in any way
that you wish you can you see the
standard template library or you can use
your own class the important thing is
avoid making J&I calls on every frame
this is what are the methods you can use
to do that now let's talk about
leaderboards so when you when you have
leaderboard is pretty much the same as
achievements because the the method
calls are pretty similar so you have the
post submit score which is made in the
same way as post unlock achievements so
it's just run on UI thread and instead
of that we're posting to the UI thread
and then on the UI thread we're calling
game game client dot submit score so
that's what's at what's actually
unlocking I mean something is submitting
the score and then from native code
we're going to write a very similar
method as in unlock achievement which
simply gets the ID of that of that
method and then makes a method call and
passes the score that you want to submit
to the leaderboard and then you call the
method and you delete the local
reference and that's pretty much all
there is to it now we have achievements
and leaderboards in your native game so
thank you very much and please watch our
next episode in which we're going to
talk about how to do more complex
complicated stuff in the native side
thank you